time is ticking away in the key German
state of Bavaria the state election
campaigns come to a close and even the
poll say it's time for a historic change
sister party to Angela Merkel's CDU the
CSU looks set to lose the dominance it's
held in Bavaria since the Second World
War even taste and tradition is
apparently losing its appeal
[Music]
now the CSU's launched major rallies in
the desperate and final attempt to
attract voters a voter swing of Angela
Merkel's compassionate my grouse stance
is expected Bavaria took in the second
highest number of asylum seekers out of
16 regions in the country at the height
of the migrant crisis twenty thousand
arrived at Munich Central Station but
everyone was happy about it now the
alternative for Germany party or the AFD
is on the verge of entering Bavarian
Parliament for the first time they're
even claiming that the ruling Bavarian
party is stealing the campaign talking
points this is very well known among the
journalists and also among the people
that did see is who is kind of copying
our program but it says always losing
massively losing the people and we got a
big part of the electorate if this is
the case then the gamble may have
backfired those who are more
conservative and leaning towards the AFD
however those put off by the rhetoric
are leaning towards the left towards the
green they're expected to come second
with 20% of the votes the absolute
majority of the CSU will be history
whatever the outcome one thing's for
sure the vote in Germany's most
influential regional governments
could have implications in national
politics and Merkel's coalition many
people and even specialists says this is
going to be the end of the coalition in
Berlin we heard this already several
times in the past and what we see is
that everybody in the government is
sticking on its chair and especially
angle America - so I'm not so sure that
the Coalition will fail apart they will
try to stay on power as long as possible
you